this video is made possible by a stream
by clicking the link in the description
you'll also get nebula for free
streaming platform made by and for
creators like me
needless to say Kevin intentionally
caused quite a bit of bodily harm to
both Harry and Marv for example you
could argue that Kevin McCallister is a
criminal mastermind up there with jigsaw
and Martha Stewart keep the change of
filthy animal
[Music]
hey legal eagles and welcome back to
laws broken where an attorney destroys
your favorite childhood movies by
showing you how illegal everything is
because everything is illegal now I'm
sure most of you have seen home alone at
one time or another you know it's the
heartwarming holiday movie where
Macaulay Culkin aka Kevin McCallister
gets left behind by his 25 person family
right before Christmas and then has to
fight off a pair of criminals who were
determined to rob his house and kill him
you know the typical heartwarming family
Christmas movie or at the very least
kids die hard
now obviously Harry and Marv aka the Wet
Bandits
are criminals will go into great detail
about their criminal exploits but is it
possible that other characters may be
far more sinister than the Wet Bandits
is it possible that Harry and Marv
simply had the misfortune to stumble
upon a nefarious criminal enterprise
already in progress well let's start by
examining perhaps the true criminals of
this holiday movie the worst parents in
the world
mr. and mrs. MacAllister now as we all
know the power goes out at the McAlister
residence the night before they're
scheduled for an international flight to
Paris and when they wake up in the
morning they rush to get to the plane
with only 45 minutes before their plane
takes off and once on the plane Kevin's
mom famously says hope we didn't forget
anything
unfortunately Kevin's parents have left
him home alone I've made my family
disappear no Kevin didn't make his
parents disappear they abandoned him
it makes you feel any better I forgot my
reading glasses and I'm sure many of you
feel for the McCallister's and realize
it's not that easy to keep track of so
many kids but in reality both mr. and
mrs. MacAllister could be found guilty
of either child abandonment or child
endangerment a person commits child
abandonment when he or she as a parent
guardian or other person having physical
custody or control of a child without
regard for the mental or physical health
safety or welfare of that child
knowingly leaves that child who is under
the age of 13 without supervision by a
responsible person over the age of 14
for a period of 24 hours or more
now here kevin is a mere 8 years old 5
years younger than the minimum age under
the child abandonment statute and he's
left alone all by himself without any
kind of supervision
gosh I'm eating junk and watching
rubbish you better come out and stop me
no I'm sure the McCallister's would
argue that they didn't knowingly leave
Kevin all alone it was just a horrible
mistake did you count heads 11 including
me 5 boys 6 girls for parents to drivers
and a partridge in a pear tree now
unfortunately for the McCallister's
getting stuck on the plane and
eventually the airport in Paris doesn't
necessarily help them all that much it
might drop the charge down from child
abandonment to just simply negligent
parenting but the bottom line is that
kevin was probably home alone for
multiple days without any supervision
such abandonment could amount to a class
4 felony in Illinois I mean Kevin is a
small child who can't even pack his own
suitcase
he's what the French call DOM and what's
worse is Kevin's parents could also be
found guilty of child endangerment for
leaving him all alone in Illinois a
person who causes or permits a child to
be placed in a situation which in
dangers the child's life or health could
be guilty of a Class A misdemeanor so
maybe next time the McAlister should
keep track of where their children are
or do you know set multiple alarm so
they're not late for their flight and by
the way stick around until the end of
this video where I give a verdict for
how long everyone including Kevin's
parents are going to jail but that takes
us to the most traditional criminal
wrongdoers in this whole affair the
so-called Wet Bandits themselves Harry
and Marv
now of course Harry starts off the movie
strong by dressing up like
a police officer quite clearly Harry is
impersonating a police officer to get
some inside Intel on the McCallister's
holiday plans that is that they'll be
out of town during the holidays
leaving the perfect opportunity for a
career burglar to break in and take
whatever the McCallister's have you're
taking a trip to Paris yes we hope to
leave tomorrow morning
excellent now the McCallister's live in
Winnetka Illinois and Illinois as in any
other jurisdiction in the United States
it is completely illegal to impersonate
a police officer in Illinois this
particular criminal offense is called
false personation I can get you up to
three years in prison
among other sentences so think about
that next time you and your friends
decide to dress up as the fuzz for
Halloween that's a good idea
so now with all of this fraudulently
acquired information about when all the
neighbors are going to leave town Harry
and Marv sit down and conveniently
conspire to commit burglary criminal
trespass and grand larceny check it out
all the houses with nobody home have
automatic timers on their lights but I
got it all figured out watch this now
because Marv has entered into a
conspiracy with Harry he's now on the
hook for all the crimes that Harry has
committed in furtherance of this
conspiracy so that means Marv is also
now on the hook for criminal
impersonation as part of that criminal
conspiracy Harry and Marv attempt to
burgle the McCallister house but are
only thwarted at the last minute when
they get spooked by Kevin get the hell
out of here
one to ten
and although Harry and Marv are
temporarily dissuaded from robbing the
McAlister house they lick their wounds
and simply drive down the road to then
burgle some other neighbor's house
instead clearly another example of grand
larceny but because they are the
eponymous Wet Bandits they can't help
themselves but clog up the sinks in the
house - cause wanton destruction of
property so again even though it's only
Marv that is committing this felonious
act both of them are on the hook for
intentional destruction of property
these people won't be back for days and
the Wet Bandits have struck leaving
their house in shambles now in between
their various burglaries the two could
probably also be convicted of stalking
in Illinois if someone simply engages in
a course of conduct which they know
would cause the target or a person to
fear for their safety they may be guilty
of stalking and here Harry and Marv are
driving around the neighborhood in a
creepy work van following little Kevin
McAllister in probably such a way that
would cause him to fear for his safety
and finally after Harry and Mars attempt
to burgle the McCallister's as Kevin
gets the best of them they attempt to
seriously maim or kill Kevin for all of
his traps be outsmarted you this time
but luckily they get bashed in the head
by a kind old man wait now given the
severity of what Harry says he's going
to do to Kevin we're gonna do to Harry
do exactly what he did to us
well burn his head with a blow torch and
given that he is in the heat of the
moment this is probably attempted
second-degree murder but now let's talk
about how Harry and Marv found
themselves in this situation let's talk
about the criminal liability of little
Kevin McCallister aka the puppet master
like most criminals Kevin starts off
small he starts off the movie by
assaulting his older brother buzz simply
for some harmless taunting oh yeah we
did
laughs you want any somebody's gonna
have to barf it all then having acquired
a taste for blood
Kevin moves on to the wanton destruction
of Buzz's property and theft now
arguably this wasn't done intentionally
so perhaps the destruction of property
gets knocked down to simply negligent
destruction of property but he's very
clearly stealing from his older brother
savings and to add insult to injury the
heartless then taunts Buzz's girlfriend
girlfriend woof now having been
emboldened by petty theft
Kevin moves on to some public
shoplifting
wait son you have to pay for that
toothbrush sad hey and while Kevin seems
like the victim in this situation I
assure you he is not shoplifter
and although kevin didn't quite intend
to take the toothbrush when he ran out
of the store one could argue that he's
guilty of what's called retail theft
under Illinois law because he knowingly
carried the toothbrush away from him and
away from the store but all of those
offences were simply baby town frolics
in preparation for the main event can
Kevin McAllister really create a
nightmare house of booby traps to punish
Harry and Marv for the attempt to burgle
his own house well in Illinois in the
absence of any defenses one is guilty of
battery and probably assault as well if
they cause bodily harm to an individual
needless to say Kevin intentionally
caused quite a bit of bodily harm to
both Harry and Marv for example you can
argue that Kevin McCallister is a
criminal mastermind up there with jigsaw
and Martha Stewart look what you did you
little jerk I'm sorry
now if convicted of battery Kevin could
receive up to a year in jail for each
attempt though that sentence would
probably be modified since he's a
juvenile and wouldn't likely be tried as
an adult
though the complexity of these death
traps does evidence an adult like
temperament if not straight-up psychosis
you guys give up thirsty for more
however thankfully for Kevin Illinois
statutes allow for both self defense and
defense of the home that means that in
certain cases one can use physical force
to defend themselves against another or
to defend their property so long as
Kevin reasonably believes that force was
necessary to defend himself and his
gigantic family's home he could get off
scot-free though I think everyone knows
that the better course of action is
simply call the police instead of
rigging your house with death traps boy
Harry where'd you take your shoes off
why the hell you dressed like a chicken
now the defense of self-defense and
defense the property generally applies
to the non deadly traps but does it
apply to everything
[Music]
of course we'd love to talk about the
use of deadly force on this channel here
most of the traps in question are
arguably not inherently deadly but some
of those traps are as deadly as they get
I mean those paint cans could crush your
skull and that's a flamethrower so
generally speaking a person can use non
deadly force against another when he or
she reasonably believes that is
necessary to prevent or terminate
another's unlawful entry into or attack
onto a dwelling now under Illinois law a
person can only use deadly force if an
entry to the house is made in a violent
riotous or tumultuous manner and there
is a reasonable belief that the force is
necessary to prevent an assault or
personal violence against the victim or
another in the dwelling or if the person
reasonably believes the force is
necessary to prevent a felony from being
committed so is that standard met well
Marvin Harry enter multiple times
sometimes quietly we know that you're in
there and that your although sometimes
in ways that might be considered violent
Rytas or tumultuous
[Music]
where are you little creep and by the
way if you want to know what happened in
the real-life case of when someone
rigged up a shotgun booby trap in their
own house check out the link in the
description to the animated true crime
video that I just did about the case of
the shotgun booby trap the link is in
the description so we know that the
first element for use of deadly force is
probably meant under these circumstances
but when you're talking about entering
into the house a few of you real legal
eagles out there probably thinking about
the duty to retreat because at common
law you can't use deadly force if you
have the ability to retreat safely and
some states have passed so-called castle
or Stand Your Ground laws that reverse
the common-law rule and allow you to use
deadly force whether you can safely
retreat or not and Illinois as it
happens doesn't have a stand-your-ground
law but it does have a castle law so to
the extent that Kevin is using deadly
force in self-defense in his own home he
does not have a duty to retreat and he
can use deadly force in self-defense
keep the change but that complicates
things because Kevin eventually leaves
his own house and so having retreated
from his home he can no longer use
deadly force to defend himself because
he can retreat safely so cutting Harry
and Marv down is arguably battery if not
attempted murder given how high they are
up in the air hey guys check this out
the little psychopath has really grown
up keep the change ya filthy animal
now before we tally up all the sentences
let's spend a moment to examine the
little crimes that are just too small to
go into any particular detail like the
pizza boy is destruction of property and
reckless driving
Uncle Frank's casual theft and use of
illegal fireworks indoors cool
firecrackers I'll save these for later
but alright it's time for a verdict
let's tally up the crimes so let's start
with Kevin's parents mr. and mrs.
McAllister they are accused of felony
child abandonment and child endangerment
I hope you don't mean that that carries
with it a maximum sentence of 6 years in
prison but given the mitigating
circumstances the first-time offense and
the fact that Kevin lived a life of
luxury when he wasn't abandoned they'd
probably get a year of probation and I
think that we can assume that Peter
McAllister would hire a really good
lawyer because it appears to be
incredibly wealthy am i under arrest or
something that brings us to Harry and
Marv they're accused of dozens of
burglaries as proven by their wet bandit
calling card
nice move always leaving the water
running now we know each and every house
that you've hit each one carries with it
a maximum of 7 years in prison in total
they'd probably look at five to ten
years in jail for the burglaries then
they'd get six years in jail for
impersonating a police officer
then for the attempted homicide of Kevin
McAllister or at least the aggravated
battery of a minor tack on another ten
years finally that takes us to the
puppet master himself Kevin McCallister
his shoplifting would be pleaded down to
a misdemeanor at most now attempted
homicide would normally carry at least a
five to ten year penalty under these
circumstances but no jury would ever
convict an eight-year-old of living out
a revenge fantasy in the suburbs of
Illinois so the puppet master goes free
to maim and kill again
did I burn down the joint I don't think
so
while Kevin created a fun house of
horrors for Harry and Marv my friends
and I were busy building a playground
for YouTube creators in fact if you
liked this episode I posted all of my
bloopers exclusively on our own
streaming platform hell of a lot
it's called nebula and we are thrilled
to be partnering with curiosity stream
we built nebula as a place where
creators don't need to worry about D
monetization or the dreaded algorithm in
fact I wouldn't be surprised if I got D
monetized for showing scenes from a PG
movie won't someone please think of the
children
hello because it's hard out there being
a creator nebula is a place where
creators can do what they do best create
it's a place where we can both house our
content ad free and also experiment with
new original series that probably
wouldn't work on YouTube because of the
algorithm for less than 20 cents per day
or 20 dollars a year you can help a
struggling youtuber link in the
description when I say that nebula is
built by creators for creators I really
mean it nebula features lots of
YouTube's top educational ish creators
like real engineering half is
interesting tears ooh knowing better
real life lore and tons of others we
also get to collaborate in ways that
probably wouldn't work on YouTube for
example the nebula exclusive series
called working titles where every
episode a different creator breaks down
their favorite TV intro sequence
polyphonic did Game of Thrones Mia
molder did Battlestar Galactica and I'll
be covering Law & Order very very soon
seriously we worked really hard on this
and we were really proud of the results
the project is self-funded it were not
backed by investors and we managed to
make all this ad free with no dreaded
algorithm there's plenty more where that
came from so what does this have to do
with curiosity Street well they love
educational content and educational
creators so they are a perfect partner
for nebula we just recently worked out a
deal where if you sign up for curiosity
stream with a link in the description
not only will you get a one-month free
trial for curiosity stream but you'll
also get a nebula subscription for free
and to be clear that nebula subscription
is not a trial it's free for as long as
you're a curiosity stream member which
means that for less than $20 a year not
only do you get unlimited access to
curiosity streams massive library of
gorgeous high budget documentaries
you'll also get to enjoy the private
playground of YouTube's best educational
creators for no additional charge and
you'll be supporting creators like me
directly just go to curiosity stream
comm slash legal eagle so if you sign up
using that link below not only will you
be able to access curiosity streams
amazing documentaries like 101 events
that made the 20th century which
includes my favorite episode on
Watergate for reasons that should be
obvious but you'll also get a
subscription to nebula for as long as
you're a member to curiosity stream
seriously it's less than 20 bucks a year
just click on the link so do you agree
with my verdict leave your objections in
the comments and check out how many laws
were broken in your other favorite
movies like Jurassic Park and the Dark
Knight over here in this playlist where
I'll see you in court